E aí
[Música]
se você é um líder
e talvez você não tenha conseguido
responder essa pergunta rapidamente
porque você nunca tinha pensado sobre
isso antes ou até mesmo porque você não
tem Claro o que é esse conceito ainda
para você então deixa eu reformular
minha pergunta
se você se parece um líder
e quando você chega em uma sala as
pessoas reconhecem essa característica
em você
e o que são as suas características que
te permitem dizer que você é o líder
bom e como elas estão presentes no seu
dia a dia hoje
e talvez quando você ouviu essas
perguntas você formou a imagem de um
líder na sua cabeça e para alguns essa
imagem pode ter sido a de um líder
político
oi ou então talvez a imagem de um líder
Capitão do seu time de futebol e várias
outras imagens de lideranças clichês que
podem ter aparecido como diretor da sua
empresa um super-herói ou até mesmo
líder religioso independente disso
independente desse contexto Independente
de ser terno gravata e camiseta de time
Suada eu tenho certeza que todos esses
são líderes por contextos necessidades e
momentos diferentes em algum momento
eles precisarão ter atitudes junto com
as pessoas que estavam ao redor deles
que foram diferenciadas e tornaram eles
líderes
e por isso eu vou voltar a te perguntar
você se parece um líder
e talvez não existe essa definição de
parecer um líder de ser um conjunto de
atributos físicos que definem essa sua
característica de liderança porque eu
tenho certeza que eu não pareço Eu tenho
24 anos moro com meus pais uso roupas
casuais não tenho barba então eu tenho
certeza que eu estou bem longe do padrão
idealizado de líderes hoje
é mas se eu estou longe desse padrão e
mais uma vez eu quero reforçar que não
existem esses líderes ideais porque você
ainda se define por um conjunto de
características físicas
bom então eu vou mais uma vez voltar na
pergunta inicial
se você é um líder
ó e aqui eu quero reportar a ação eu
quero reforçar o verbo porque ser um
líder é sobre um conjunto de atitudes e
comportamentos são um conjunto de ações
que você precisa ter no dia a dia que
vão tornar você nessa condição de
liderança
é mas na verdade por que que essa
pergunta causa tanto incômodo assim para
ser respondida
é porque você não tem clareza e
tranquilidade para dizer que tem orgulho
dessa condição desse estado de ser líder
hoje
hoje eu vim aqui porque sim eu tenho
orgulho tenho tranquilidade para dizer
que Independente de ter 24 anos e todas
as outras características que podem
limitar que estão imperceptíveis ou não
Hoje eu sou um líder
bom e quando eu digo isso Calma não
precisa imaginar aquele Líder igual Cafu
ou Obama um líder grandioso com impacto
Mundial um líder que talvez esteja tá
inalcançável Diante da sua realidade
hoje porque quando você construiu aquela
imagem de líder Você não pensou talvez
na Nati Natura uma influência digital
uma personificação de uma marca que
mostra todos os dias como é ser mulher
seja nas suas qualidades nos seus
defeitos nas dificuldades que ela tem Ou
talvez no favelado investidor uma pessoa
que busca trazer a educação financeira
para pessoas em comunidades que Muito
provavelmente não tinham acesso a esse
conhecimento antes disso
e São pessoas que têm atitude simples
atitudes do dia a dia que estão aqui ao
seu alcance questão sim nessa condição
de líderes hoje
bom e quando eu digo isso Calma não
precisa achar que você não tem ambição
você não tem direito ou você não pode
sonhar em ser um líder com o impacto tão
grande quanto aqueles que você idealizou
que você imaginou quando você ouve a
ideia de liderança você pode se
interações para isso você pode ter os
sonhos disso O que um líder não pode
fazer é ficar parado achando que vai
alcançar esse caminho de uma hora para
outra porque um líder precisa trabalhar
com propósito e talvez esse tenha sido o
maior aprendizado que eu tive em 2020
e nesse ano eu tive a oportunidade de
ser sim eu daí exec uma organização
voluntária aqui em Belo Horizonte que
trabalha com mais de 100 jovens todos os
dias buscando desenvolver cada vez mais
esse propósito de liderança e quando eu
digo propósito Talvez isso seja até
mesmo uma coisa maior do que eu que eu
não vou ver se é concluída que eu não
vou ver ser atingido e por exemplo a
gente pode trazer até a campanha do
Obama o Yasmin quem de quando ele trouxe
um conceito de que toda uma nação
poderia ser melhor ou cê 100% Jardim de
100 porcento jardim com carro em que ele
trouxe visibilidade para uma comunidade
que não era reconhecida que não tinha o
apoio necessário até antes dele trazer
aquele escrito na camiseta dele
E são essas ações são esses portas são
esses passos que fazem o líder trabalhar
cada vez mais para deixar o seu legado
para alcançar aquele propósito
impossível porque um líder precisa ter
responsabilidade com esse propósito
é um líder precisa ser a pessoa que está
movendo correntes que tá fazendo ação
que não fica parado para alcançar esse
propósito
bom e quando estamos falando sobre
escolher ser líder em 2020 é bem claro
todo o contexto social económico
político que estamos vivendo que pode
ter sido intensificado por um contexto
sanitário imprevisível Também ou talvez
seja escancarado a palavra certa
contextos que às vezes estão ou não
dentro do seu controle Mas independente
disso um líder precisa tomar as suas
responsabilidades de acordo com o seu
propósito
bom e é por isso que um líder precisa
ter evoluções um líder precisa saber que
está passando por cinco dias
aprendizados que vai estar sempre em um
constante movimento e podem existir
exceções a essa regra Claro infelizmente
eu não fui um desses e para mim esse
ciclo começa naquele momento que eu
passei a desejar alguma coisa esse ponto
inicial de querer aprender sobre algo de
planejar alguma coisa maior e talvez
isso seja sobre uma ferramenta que você
ainda não sabe usar talvez estejam uma
habilidade que você não tem um contato
que você ainda não acessou até o momento
que você consegue que você alcança isso
e a partir daí você passa só executar as
suas ações
se você passa a aproveitar o momento e
Navegar como se fosse um mar tranquilo a
brisa leve que as coisas estão dando
certas até que acontece aquele primeiro
erro aquele primeiro deslize aquele
primeiro imprevisto no seu caminho
É nesse momento pode ser Talvez uma meta
que não foi atingida um comentário um
pouco mais duro do seu time um feedback
que você não estava preparado para ouvir
como líder Você vai precisar aprender a
lidar com tudo isso no seu dia a dia e
aqui nesse momento existem Duas escolhas
a primeira delas provavelmente seja mais
fácil a mais charmosa mais brilhante que
é o caminho da desistência em que você
disse que não liderança não é para você
não é esse caminho que você quer seguir
e pode ser que outra pessoa assuma essa
responsabilidade tá mais preparada tá
mais capacitada esse Com certeza é o
caminho mais fácil mas esse não é um
caminho que um líder de verdade toma
Porque no momento que você assumir a
responsabilidade com o seu propósito
você precisa encarar os seus erros
encarar o que não está acontecendo da
melhor forma possível entender como que
você precisa melhorar isso e revisar
essa situação para se tornar cada vez
melhor cada vez uma pessoa melhor
o que você tem que voltar lá naquele
ponto inicial de aprendizado de
planejamento de desenvolver uma nova
habilidade que você ainda não tinha
Antes de Voltar a fase boa da execução
tranquila
É porque quando você escolhe ser um
líder
se você precisa conscientemente se
colocar em um ciclo constante de
aprendizados de erros de falhas de
crescimento EA polícia que muita gente
engasgar na hora de responder aquela
primeira pergunta
bom e quando você é um líder você tem
que ser o primeiro a reagir as coisas
que estão acontecendo de forma errada ou
de forma imprevista
bom e é só uma situação incômoda essa é
uma situação desagradável e essa é uma
situação que pouca gente escolhe viver
é por isso que quando você escolhe ser
um líder você passa a ter claramente
dois papéis o primeiro deles você
precisa aprender a prevenir essas coisas
que estão acontecendo erradas você
precisa conseguir prever e mitigar as
consequências desses erros vão ter que
vão ter no seu contexto Enquanto isso o
seu segundo papel é o de inspirar
pessoas você precisa fazer com que todos
acreditem que vocês estão seguindo o
caminho certo que vocês estão caminhando
da melhor forma possível e que juntos
Vocês conseguem superar qualquer
adversidade
O que é o exemplo mais claro do que esse
e eu não preciso ter nenhum viesse o
apoio político aqui mas até o começo de
2020 eu nunca tinha ouvido falar sobre
essa mulher e eu acredito que muita
gente também não mas sobre ele eu tenho
certeza que todos já tinha ouvido falar
antes seja bem ou mal mas agora ao final
de 2020 eu vejo a primeira ministra Nova
Zelândia como uma Líder muito mais bem
posicionada para o seu para sua nação do
que o presidente dos Estados Unidos
É porque ela teve condição de agir
rápido diante da crise que apareceu no
ano de 2020 ela conseguiu comunicar com
clareza um plano de ação para poder
enfrentar essa situação ela conseguiu
convencer as pessoas de que esse era o
melhor plano possível e o melhor de tudo
ela teve calma suficiente para executar
esse plano ao longo do tempo e é isso
que um bom Líder precisa fazer
bom e é por isso que ser um líder me
lembra muito de escolher crescer uma
música que talvez algumas pessoas
conheçam e crescer dói mas essa é a
história de todo o herói
Ah e quando eu ouço essa música me vem
mais uma lição de aprendi uma lição de
liderança que eu tive com os meus heróis
infantis o Dumbledore Harry Potter que
dizia que felicidade pode ser encontrada
em qualquer lugar basta você se lembrar
de ser luz
bom e talvez fora do mundo das histórias
de heróis das Mundo de Magia felicidade
aqui no contexto real pode ser entendido
como liderança então basta você assumir
o seu papel e perceber que você tem sim
essa posição de líder que você consegue
trazer isso para sua realidade e eu
acredito que é bem mais fácil imaginar
que os líderes vão ser aquelas pessoas
grandes nos livros de história que tem
um impacto Mundial que você nunca vai
conseguir ser igual é muito mais
confortável achar que vai aparecer um
super-herói o Batman mulher-maravilha
alguém como superpoderes para corrigir
todo o contexto todas as coisas que
acontecem de errado hoje é muito mais
confortável isso
é mas quando você diz que você é um
líder essa posição não é sobre conforto
é uma posição em que você precisa
assumir a sua responsabilidade tem que
você precisa tomar a sua decisão e a
primeira delas é você dizer que sim você
é um líder que você deve se tornar cada
vez um líder melhor e é por isso que
quando eu digo que eu sou o líder eu
passo a ter uma noção uma condição muito
maior do impacto que eu possa ter dentro
da sociedade do Poder de transformação
que eu tenho em mim mesmo e com as
pessoas que convivem comigo também e a
responsabilidade que eu tenho para
continuar trazendo esse movimento para
todo mundo e a partir daí você passa a
ter um sentimento de pertencimento um
sentimento de realização muito grande
porque você passa a se tornar um ser
humano melhor e melhor ainda você passa
a contribuir para que outras pessoas
também sejam melhor
e isso é uma das maiores realizações que
nós podemos ter enquanto uma sociedade e
à polícia que eu vim aqui hoje para
dizer que eu acredito muito que sim
todos podem ser líderes obrigado